then as a reward for something like that
there is now and then a rail strike
demand we think is super, really
great because sometimes
the tours really go completely through the roof with
us and if you also
link it cleverly with a campaign and also use it
as a customer acquisition situation
but that's why that the business
is a lot of fun because it's
incredibly dynamic i come from
the trade where you say okay you buy
something somehow no idea design
shows so somehow
production times hate logistics has they were sold
in the season from the unbelievable
lead times  our business is
sometimes up to date when we
see the weather turning you have to think about whether
it makes good promotion now there are relatively
few even if I
have asked if you prefer car sharing
or staying put because in the rain
value can be a guest at the skoda through the area
today  is the ceo of
friedberg what most of them don't even mean
you know he's responsible for a
company worth billions the biggest app
in germany for mobility a
huge market place best listen
out theo marktberg now it's on from 9
yes it's such a billion-dollar company group
i have a hard time with
groups we are hopefully not because that's
what i associate with and how not only  positive
things i would describe it as a gamer
and billion refers to the
rating yes we
are not publicly listed
and now belong to daimler and bmw exactly
those are our two scheer and zu
but also a few
financial investors yes exactly us  have
a cab double there are the
majority with daimler and bmw holding
the 90 percent so proportionately more than 42 and
then we
still have financial investors from the earlier merger who hold about ten
percent okay okay but let’s start
at the beginning as I think there is one
background the friedenauer brand is
somehow earlier my lyrics
e.g. you used to be otto, among other things
, and even
co-founded not quite but supervisory board member and co-initiator of about you are
so i only realized shortly before the
podcast that you were somehow
somehow involved in the start almost and
then gone  gone and Klara still
done and now just to manage this scale
up tells a bit when
did it start for you although digital journey
who so I'm well what's the name right
now precaution
so end 40
570 offered
and I'll go there would have
grown up  i remember when i was
studying i didn't have anything to do with
digital is a clear and 28k modem
and that was the first time i
grew up there were no cell phones
, no smartphones and the internet was
kind of a bit strange
was that they somehow made the
fix but it hadn't really caught on with the
masses
and at the beginning i didn't have a completely
different thing apart  put it
like you typically do i
studied business administration and then ended up a
little bit on the consulting side through
internships and then he
said the process optimization i think it's
good it's so hands-on it was
fun and then after two
quite strenuous  in practice i
would do a lifestyle internship
in the city i like and
somehow didn't feel like working 18 hours a
day and when he came to
hamburg and ended up otto that
wasn't on my list at all but we
had a colleague of mine your hamburg  choice
said watch out for the companies and
they do a lot and apply
there with the history i had from
the consultancy come so that nature we
have such an in-house consultancy here
you want that would be something for an
internship for you that you a  fit quite well
and I got stuck there
I got stuck there because I
really liked it I don't know
w  arum said it always felt like a kind of
carte blanche in the company so
I always had exciting projects as an
intern it was about who do you ask
for to do i don't know i
can't do anything real you come
from the university well says yes we have
kind of a joint venture considerations
with estée lauder it's about the
origins brand we're thinking about how we
can freely develop the given together in terms of sales
they want to set up a concept in
stationary rhein and otherwise directly
represented and i was
an intern had no idea about
it  but somehow two weeks later
i was sitting as an intern with the
responsible buyer on the
plane to new york and then
sat with excel or together and with the
brand managers thought about how to
set something up in germany
so it was a super exciting year at
otto it worked  actually over how many years
the long long i.e. in total
i think i  ch almost ten years and the end
stage was then steps business
exactly that into the end stage was then hans
otto schrader at that time the first win or
not came from the family for a long time
but i think to be completely
honest and i
had already had with him before  he tends to work together
when he was responsible for the
germany business
for the large universal
mail order companies and he then offered the job of group ceo today and
asked if i
would want to be part of the group strategy for him
and then had a three-year break from ottawa, so to speak,
have a super
fun job  in switzerland
with a management for the
perfumery chain i had no
idea but she called me and
said we are looking for someone here
with direct sales competence because we
want to build up our ecommerce under catalog business and that’s also our data area back then there was still one
little bit different than today I had that for
three years g  eleiten was a lot of
fun anyway there were 120 branches
in switzerland
and i had them after three
years otto brought me
back said watch out you are doing corporate strategy here
and
then the idea came up nope that was a
bit  later that was i can do it so
i always had the problem that
i always say what i think and
that always led to trading leading to relative
friction but then it
was also a bit superior to the
overall market but either you can’t keep
up  your work or we don't have to
be held responsible for the strategy in some
way because you always
say what's right
or wrong from his point of view, so to speak, and i
was very, very strong on that
trip to say we had these three
universalists with otto bauer spart  the
very comparable range had a
bit different target groups
but if you look at it from the outside it's
ok  t naively i always thought
i have to put them all together
you have to do it much more synergistically and
actually you also have to
consider whether the business model of the future
or should we actually invest a lot more
logistics and financial services
that went very well back
then and then  then everyone
said that all of a sudden i
had to sit down, really
think about it, zalando also managed, yes, what can
we do as the otto group and really make
another real
attack and therefore discussed back and forth a bit,
namely said, well, i
'm determined  not the one who now has
the great idea, but
i got to know people over the years
and if i say now i can look for a
few people from the group
and get alexander to join them, then i would think about talking to them
at least once a month
about whether  we would
somehow come up with a starting point
and then there was one  en very
entertaining appointment where then alex
kraft came along tarik was there acts like
she was with a team at that time was
also there and as for others and we
sat there and thought about whether a warehouse will be
built anyway which warehouse is for it,
so to speak, the mail order whole 1 and
load and logistic that was like that
alex graf i was also very strong in
the sheen sounds kinda very
reasonable and harry can then
at some point come up with the idea of this to the origi
al idea of the farmers uva but not too mat
rialized was very important
at the beginning it was in the sense of what
can be done on the goal is or others there are
few innovations ecommerce because the
barriers to entry are actually quite high there has to be something was at the stand buy dropshipping wasn't particularly large at the time
you had to
have a range you had to be able to pay dirk adams is
everything  annoying but to think about how to
sell was that is exciting and
somehow innovative and that the
people stay tuned there are extremely
few because these hurdles are extremely high at the beginning
initially with three
products then try to
sell them in spans but if you
could give renewed access to a platform you
say the range is there and i
thought about giving people so to speak
how an app store accessed you
can build an app on my range
and sell it that was a consideration
as I said, you can sort of
buy the assets that the otto group
had in the sense of we can
buy logistics we can distribution
we can  peyman so all infrastructure issues
and we are building a platform on this
creative allows products to be played and
sold specifically to target groups that
could only have them so i wanted
to develop somewhere else meanwhile
i will present this date there
is this legend in hamburg of the
house where udo used to be  lindenberg and i
believe that müller westernhagen otto and
used to live that old and
i think in the 70s there was such a
shared flat that’s a bit like this now too
this date if he now alex graf
who’s going to build a billion-dollar company it’s
just a few corners retail giant have
somehow built a billion-dollar corporation
with you  you were smaller and
so also infinite billions of companies
meanwhile
already like millionaires women or
directors club making well it
certainly didn’t feel that different back then
it was a very
funny creative but also very
critical workshop in the sense of saying
what are we actually really
good at  nevertheless the bavaria was just a
striker still there a dear pc
or former bcg partner who
has since stopped there the
simple very good more critical than
bearings partner is well then no
company founded somehow not so
i would made the teachers harmful at
some point and then it was gbc
stopped but that was that was the
biggest we  d krueger but there
was also someone who was on my
team so a colleague women at a Oktoberfest was
very very strong the topic
looks like how does business planning
look exploited financial models behind it but
after this appointment you will be
the founder shortly afterwards  still planning to get out of otto
then
, various people weren’t quite honest,
was still two or three years at auto
and then developed out of it as the group in
dispute because i
personally really enjoy
financial services and everything we had
at the time, the somehow digital
financial product and the newspaper products
so we said before come on motto
today understand the retail trade we
have to get closer to digital values i was still
driving a car we st
rted discussing saying it toget
er with olaf rodax tell me how big is th
online share at otto back then the 3
percent discussed  because it would be a 20
or 50 or 75 percent and what
speed  that happened
and otto was actually the
only one who really managed to do it reasonably in transformation for the senders in germany europe
and mine i would still fresh
but contradict yes yes yes is
reasonable compared to others
i think
all dead and otto have done it better  still alive and
actually also live and kicking i
would say of course there are
challenges but and of course
she doesn't see amazon but she seems
to be successful there they have really found her target group
but
i haven't been out
that long so i'm not anymore
I then dealt with the
subject of payment for a while because there
was only spader, there was ratepay,
everyone was thinking about the choice of mobile payment
and they are ok, so ebay
and paypal have and how it works and
then consideration can be ok  you
actually use the platform we
have to launch more products
and
I personally let myself be infected by the
mobile payment hype,
there was something special about it and everyone was
talking that the big
revolutionary technology will be burning, which
will also revolutionize paid and the topic
and then we built the company that
was called kapital
and they had it  but when this winkler is
involved, i am very intensively looked after from the bottom up, so to speak
,
but that didn't work, so that's
really what we have to say today,
unfortunately, that was one of the biggest
failures i had because we
underestimated how unbelievably
difficult it is a two-sided
building a payment system, i.e. a closed loop
system where the retailer side and
the customer side have to scale in parallel,
because if you’re missing one, it
can be said to work,
so either you have retailers and no
customers then it’s difficult because
saying that gets a transaction volume
I don't need the time or what
customers and no huh  ndlers then the
customers say payment today if I
can use that somewhere, so to speak, that means
this parallel scaling up to
the market place is incredibly
difficult, but then you can’t use it
with a payment but convince the dealers
and the customers
then want to  buy with it yes we
can, of course it does,
but i'm going to be like that at some point
after 23 years out then i was
approached by little little if i
didn't
buy the immediately transfer
and hadn't properly integrated it
into the group  somehow also had such
a challenge is i
actually doing it that feels like
a foreign body how should you
not progress as fast as
we actually want with a smaller germany also had a
bit of a change in personnel in the
position then said you didn’t
want to do that  tasks relatively clear
you have to consider medical and
immediate transfer u  and we get a
small one in germany austria
switzerland back on the growth course
an exciting task and i from
planner super interesting also
noticed compared to ratepay they
were much more advanced and even
technologically more advanced i
switched to it and then exactly this
topic came up you can  don't
actually convince dealers to stick with it, so to speak
, the problem is with dealers,
payment is for them a bit like
electricity from the socket for
us because I can deal with it
that has no customer
differentiating feature it's possible today
that credit cards paypal why
needed a new payment method  the principle is
something that should work as cheaply as possible without
any problems and a payer has to be
integrated if it's not just
a credit card, it's quite a lot of
work, so integrating a second invoice and purchase on
account is a
big technical project that's
about the erp interfaces in that  is
w  Real engineering effort that the
dealers have to provide for this and then think about it
yourself as a dealer
, saying why should I do that, it
works, but he I
really want to touch it is that you have the
highest greatest opportunity I have
or shouldn’t I rather
always have a new web shop somehow  investing in new
product ranges can improve, for example, etc. ie from a retailer logic you have
that's why you hardly have the
payment already that's something like that
nobody wants to worry about it if it
works everyone is happy and
compared to the shopping baskets
the payment is also a cost  relatively manageable
that's not a huge
cost item your incredibly hurts
like logistics costs or something like that
that's like once it's going well
then almost not all of it anymore unless I
change one shop platform or I
change rp systems or somehow my
payment  provider has annoyed me so much
that I'm just angry and I say
put it in your hand now ok it means
that was we will find the problem later there
will be several problems yes the
technology was simply not there yet there
has now been so
we also used qr code
scanning technology back then to simply create
this coupling  i
was made intelligent because the
consideration was how you can
build up a dealer sales network really quickly
without having to acquire every retailer
and that the team found a good
solution how to use the existing terminal via existing
credit card interfaces
and
actually engineering effort for the
big ones  psp it was like the terminal
operators were like a
concardis or no idea what is the name of this big
terminal provider in germany needs
have been out too long
[music]
doesn't come on it so also
two sections a chapter capital which in
the end yes me actors  that's
very exciting what exciting  it was also
a lot of fun but also
saw how quickly something like this can't
work out even though you are actually
convinced of the idea that it worked well
and when it was clear
then it was easier right away because there
was added value and it was clear too
not easier clearer had the great
advantage that you could prove very well with numbers
that a purchase on account
product and combine purchase on account
product planner increases the shopping baskets and
that was then directly driving sales
for the dealer, so to speak, and then it is
also not relevant the basic
consideration is yes that if  you have a
credit card you have your
paypal will be debited directly to your account so you
order something you have debited the caps or
your credit card and in principle
this credit line is missing if a purchase
on account you as a customer
have no debit at first you are paying
you can do a lot  buy more rather make
a selection order
and you pay d  u what you
keep means the real bodies were
demonstrably higher and what we
saw is that the profitability was, so to speak,
despite the high tribute and
actually higher the customers kept more goods
and that the
story on the tour is just that  an
expensive tour so it's clear there was
n't the classic had
created added value for harald kieffer
roast or later met pay later that
's what we're looking at now somehow about
different places and that's
what had already rolled up the market back then
with that you have
rolled up the market and was really really
successful so that was exactly that was so
much fun so it was
one of two years we became the clear
number one of course
I bought billpay back then so it was a
super super exciting time it was really a lot of
fun  and that's meanwhile
today we're talking about 40 will be 15 years
and yes there are that's 46
billion  en i think is the last
rating that is there so i
guess yes i still have shares okay
then it was a completely good
day never was an exciting time i
would of course like to have more shares yes that
has been a question of that for over  time
when is a super exciting time
also a super good team has an
unbelievable speed that for
me says a lot to learning from
the potter universe where i actually have
the feeling i'm one of the
fast ones out there
compared to clara where  i somehow felt like
someone was already standing there an ic
drives past me so this
sebastian has this the mindset of the
royal children sebastian latowski had to be such
that my time was shaped to make
quick decisions per se is a
quality feature and if it's wrong
you have to be quick  correct but
anyway an 80 20 decision is a
very good decision he didn't attach importance
to seeing everything through to the end
analyze what he was for the history
was socialized from the car and
that stands at the beginning where i said
the rebranding immediately for example
that wasn't that we've
done an incredible number of ab tests are about
what is a performance abegg in bed
when we  do the rebranding and so
on and orange suddenly
turns pink and Sofortüberweisung disappeared very
strong brand in the German payment market
but he said what the strategy
is quite clear I want to have a
brand yes and we will do that now
yes and maybe we will  we were struggling a
bit but it's still
the right way we
're just going through with it ok and you left anyway
and then let yourself be
poached yes the background was
I was looking for them at the time for
three specific tasks integration
is immediate transfer that  to boost growth in
germany
austria switzerland and another one at
one  pay later vendors to buy are
the green picture while said
it takes three maybe four
years and a lot of things
just really came together by chance
the picture during a
sales process we
were able to conclude that the
integration went much faster straight away
when we had
planned that and that the market was also
growing so that there really was a
window of opportunity four-legged pallet
products and market growth also
scaled strongly and i was lucky to
have the right people to build the
team i was through after two
years and had  then also thought about what
am i doing here now because part of the
task was also to centralize the added value
in stockheim more for the topic of branding
for the topic of
engineering that's why the
integration of immediately was important in
principle I had
marketing sales pr & communication there afterwards said
is the better sales people a  ls me
, well, there are a lot of people who
can do that better and then after the
task I visited where I
can take care of companies holistically again
and not just, so to speak, just look after the
commercial or the
sales side and then mytaxi came to me
at that time exactly at that time karamatic them  got a
call and actually i
wasn't on vacation at all and didn't feel like
thinking about it at all
and said yes once but it's
about a company in hamburg and
it's in the corner area of germany, so to speak, and t
at's why it can't exist at all
but when I said there was
another taxi, I said that's
exciting because it's the one
app I had on it very early on as a
user where I was totally excited because that's the
first time this app is used what
is it for  some user proposition i
see where the taxi is coming i have to
stand outside i can use my paypal account
i always had cash
totally annoying so ever  I said
it's really exciting I said
I'd like to listen to it and
then got into the conversation and how big
was my text ever at Taxi
I think with the acquisitions you
made it was already relatively big instead of
650 700 employees yes  the
company had made some acquisitions
sexy was, so to speak, the nucleus of
the history of the founding of
mytaxi i know the green one a
bit in hamburg so not that the
founding is so that the two of them didn't matter to
us if somehow supposedly we were out and about in
munich in the evening and were
partying properly and somehow
stumbled out of the club at night
and somehow tried
to find out at the central taxi number and did
n't work and said
it's also totally hamburg
sometimes want an app like that and originally
taxis thought of it as a solution  as a
bidder or as a saas solution for
taxi centers so they wanted to
go to taxi centers  point out that people or
cruisers as one thing we actually offer you
the the software
solution that you can control directly via an epoch and
we don't always
have to take calls and the taxi service
center has refused it
says there's no match between us and our customers
and that that  doesn't work either
and so they started to set up their own test
to say that the software
also works and noticed that
it scaled really well at the time collected a
bit of money through family & friends
when the
iphone didn't exactly come out and nothing from you came
out and  they used that as sales
about something we give
every taxi driver an iphone if he
drives for us and accepts tours and that was
the founding story
that scaled so well that they said we’d
forget this tobi story but
actually focus on him too
director consumer area why is
my text with ext  rem
difficult questions why is my taxi
no longer called that wasn't that a strong
burns a look yes city wins so
the nice thing about the brend mytaxi was yes
you made ne so in category concept to the
brand then because it's there with taxi
that means organic looking for the  you have for
apps or what other service is yes
if you say i'm looking for a taxi in
hamburg then my taxi alone as a name
in taxi has always been at the top that
means a lot of organic user info has been
the problem with the category terms
is that you  the category
murderer is set so if you are now
thinking how did it actually
develop for him we have
a taxi it is only one single
factor that is available with us but platform
yes we also have the
private party business i.e. the
licensed private  rental car business
that your direction is actually towards the
top of this world then
we have integrated it well we have integrated ebikes
we've integrated car sharing so we're going to do
public
transportation tests now, that means we'll
be doing the platform has developed so much
further that it would have
been difficult to convey it under the mytaxi brand
, at least from nike and in the
sense of they're just looking for a
taxi dispatcher but not for  an
app that is actually supposed to
manage mobility ok so since then it
has to be where it
has to be said at the beginning somehow
certainly worth billions there are
also the rumors that there are always
offers about
your gifts in the area of how much
ales you make  how freenet is currently
is a good question i don't think it's
allowed to say anything about it because the
background isn't because we're shying away in
any way i actually
like to communicate that because you're also
comparable in the team because
we've built up large companies
but we have two listed
companies  yes and there must  s you always have to be
careful who is actually allowed
to say anything about sales and profit figures
there is a clear guideline the
only one who
communicates
sales and profit figures that the group i.e. daimler and bmw are allowed to
communicate what the last thing they
also how they communicate no
sales on  individual levels of participation
i don't know why you're doing it then
you would have to ask them what we're
allowed to communicate is our platform
turnover then so that's how much
transaction volume we have via our we
'll make our platform
corona and hit so before krone
in 2009 there were 10  we really did with around two
billion platform sales at others in
january february in 20 20
and that was with 100 percent growth compared to
18 and also in 20 20 we
had extremely high growth again, sometimes
over 100 percent that means we would probably have kept
the 33 1  we
had the arm platform sales if
kohl but that means then  including the
things passed on to others
yes we only act
as intermediaries we no longer own anything the taxes do not belong to
us
he must also know the other
things that are sometimes assigned to you based on the
name i also
have a pair of scissors i.e. those  car is
car sharing car sharing so manageable
it says yes the idea from so to speak the
eats out by separate already belongs
to the same family as go but it does
n’t he but again much bigger
but they have the seats the hardware
they the cars and china so that’s it
sometimes a bit complicated to start with
if so if i'm the last one
trying to somehow
argue that maybe that's the
glass of the rebranding of all times the
idea at the time was for the shareholder to
say we want different ones so overall
mobility is a problem we
have different ones  to make mobility service providers available to
our customers in our family
either via mytaxi back then or via
car to go and schernau those were the
two 35 me that yes back then at bmw
you have to have the two carsharing
amalgamated a pity the
infrastructure and marketing
infrastructure
and the idea was let's
find an umbrella brand where they could  say all of
these services
can be found again from the customer's point of view and the
idea was that you should focus on
exactly what came from the bmw family
because they already had drivenow and partner
and sharjah that you say you take
that as an umbrella term and that's why
we had to come up with a brand name  was there
something to do with the agency involved
or was that really all
no no that wasn’t an agency honestly who
did when i have a lot of respect
for the entrepreneurial
performance, especially when you look at
the cash register turned off so now
two billion flat sales are mediated
the question a commission
he get for that  our business under
the age of 18
is then 5 percent or
20 percent or 20 percent so
you can calculate that it is also
large in terms of turnover how many people
are currently working for us, around 2000 people are working for us,
so 2000 sometimes
exactly the topic hit what
is currently gas is really super
cool that German companies
suddenly have one like that actually somehow
there so if you
want to call it that of the new audi better we
know that multimodality is a topic that is
clearly in the forefront  that's something that made
a big strategic decision for us
yes i don't want to interrupt so
let's talk about a company that
i think is on the stock market for 19 years
now so it's quite right
thinks a bit lower but still a
lot more than 870 ok i have  maybe
haven't looked in a while
but let's see now they're
rated incredibly high yes so I
've already got there  well, you can like the
model or not, but that's
the way by 7 18 years, you're better
informed,
so in any case
, the topic is already impressive, but that
hits the spot and i think it's of
course still
more difficult to
identify what's there now because of these different brands  Exactly who
does and also what the performance
actually is, but with
many things the performance is immediately clear
so again for Alfredo does the
mediator you can go in with you
and that multimodal is the
key word you can go to you and
then you can  also all kinds of standing
scooters from seated scooters from
bicycles offered by others channel to
say to you then book and do I have to
log in again you have to sue him everywhere
the basic consideration maybe
sometimes a step back because I
think it’s important
to understand why  didn't
we somehow develop infusion or something like other people
if  Let's be
honest if someone used to
book a taxi with mytaxi then
they didn't want to sit in the taxi yes they
somehow wanted to go to the airport or volt
to meet their friends for dinner in the
hospital or something else that means they
have their own needs I want
somewhere else  point out that taxi drivers are medium to
purpose is a low involvement
production but I just want to go
there and when we said then if that
is the basic need then
we leave a lot of market because there are only a
few people for a taxi yes but the
basic need of 9  coming from anna
b is actually extremely big and
that is not solved in cities yes we
see more and more form factors like
this good that you mentioned
or the e mopeds or car sharing and
i am sure we have
already seen some topics  of partners
who now want to delete somehow
a person potsdam who somehow
protected against rain and weather fully
electric so there is still a lot to come
i believe in what are so despite 1
person from covered the good in principle
yes but cannot tip over the strong on two
or three wheels which simply
gives even more flexibility to move in the city
i as little water as possible
more weatherproof would be exactly and i
think the innovation doesn't stop there yet
we would be much more so
simple i think we will appreciate that
they are designed for two
people we will see different types of e
bikes that are much easier to
ride  currently have what he likes that are
no longer that heavy that are not
that sluggish i think we will
see types of minibuses so
maybe eight to
ten people transporting people then more with virtualbox so
the conversations we are having we see
the unbelievable amount of innovation that
the problem is
i think that in the inner city
of large metropolises you don't need a
car and that's actually  i
own what we have i personally and
also a car and people ask the annual
fair how can you say your
vision is that you
no longer need a personal car in major cities in europe
because i say our world
doesn't have enough power today that
means  it has to be so strong that you
really say from a user
perspective there is always an offer
that suits me well
to move around the city and is it
financially attractive that is
cheaper for me than owning a car
full cost  what insurance garage
repairs fuel and so on is and
then in my opinion that is the value
proposition so now we can from
mytaxi and that was a fundamental
consideration we were a platform yes
our heart is a platform offer
brokers and manage supply and demand in
real time  a platform yes that's
nothing where we shop in vitoria the sale
with the trade its
principle is a real time  t balance
between supply and demand that depends
on the weather from peak times of holidays
front football stadium events or
something else and we then had
the opportunity the world cup ok our nied is
to bring the customer from a to b what
possibilities are there because we could
now have our own  buy carsharing cars
as well as scissors because our sister company
that makes me somehow has a few thousand
cars per city and tries
to leave them out or we can
try out our own good things that we buy and
offer on our platform, so to speak,
what was even tried and
there we have it  noticed in this scooter
business that is completely different from that of bob, so
the business model and the
skills are something completely different
to operate a platform, which is
basically a very technical and data-
driven topic or
to operate a good operation where a
large part of the economy from  Therein lies
the supply chain to have
things out  to get asia
was waiting to load together to redistribute in
the city that means the
technology is all good i very
very small the operations bad is
really what does not differentiate
between a very good good provider
and a very bad scooter
provider and then they say okay,
what we do is we are really good
at managing the platform, yes, we don't belong to the
mobility platform with quality and
supply, and the band belongs,
we really need those
with the best possible platform, and
we now think this through to the end and
say it  we listen to our own
business and we will bring as many
third-party providers as possible as well as taxi to
third-party providers onto our
platform and will bring this
supply to our demand in the sum goes
another way no these other we
are now going into the delivery service
areas and want to do it ourselves, so to speak
keep growing and not be this platform
why  don't do it like that
i don't know you have to ask about so
what was our consideration was that we
believe that the problem of urban
mobility is far from solved
we have no one else would have
private cars and we say the problem is
isolated when the batteries  in which
cities paris london and berlin hamburg
munich barcelona left its
triesen metropolis the so much
unprocessed market yes where i say that
the problem is so big for us
that we wo
n't reach the limits of growth in the next five to ten years
and then  it's a question of what
we're going to focus on
i want to throw myself into the food delivery services where i'm kind of rubbing
myself against
focused individual companies that are
also all worth
billions or i say
no i'm the one who is committed
to the topic of urban
mobility  problem is far from solved
and we are the ones who solve it properly
what do i hear a bit what
is called urban in germany so how
many cities does the current we
do from troy is served almost 150
cities so simply quite
a bit above yes but there has to be a bit of
differentiation so we have some
cities that we serve with our
taxi business but  we don't
actively work on it when i'm really talking about the topic of
multimodality so super exactly the
super app for mobility where i
actually register once
behind things once my payment data
i get a driver's license because
and verification with us and can then use
all the services of this platform
via  this account that we do our
goal is to do that in 30 to 40 cities in
europe because you need a
certain
basic demand so the good
operations our partners are also dependent
on sandmann that they have this service
ready in the cities so that we can
integrate them  and that doesn't make
sense if you have a city  if it has less
than canal and 50,000 inhabitants then
it will be tight depending on the business model
some can also go a little deeper
others can focus on
the questions of car sharing less
because the cars are very expensive you see from the
outside you look at everyone  original
different then again
firmly from the fact that the fund is to be
spoken to
that you can't say that at all i
think we see a lot of professions so
what we see is that the
market is becoming highly professionalized also in the
scooter sector
we are working very hard
successfully with wool together with
her we might also
integrate one or the other of them in the market
we see that they
really pay attention to the fact that the customers behave well
that's good and i've done
the favorites are that we don't have the
systems that  somehow it looks
good lying around, so they are
really, really good at operations  they are
technically good is a cooperative good that
means we see that these are really
professionally run companies
we also see what is logical in the car sharing
sector because of course the assets are
significantly more expensive and have more
value you can’t just throw a car
really amazed how they throw that
well do
that means we are seeing a strong
professionalization of the individual
providers who, so to speak, have their word of
transport who are really really good at it
and who are yours has of the competition
i
don’t believe that sixt so i have
great respect for 60 find such a
great brand and are  in the
car sharing area so no pension
area if we're honest the clear
number one is for me absolutely a model company
i think but that we'll be when we
pay for the flight so you can see who
which provider has me for
mobility actually that will be clear
before that will be now  only in the few
cities so only a year ago
we had no idea 8,000 external ones as
planned from his platform
we now have over 100,000
wraps that made me by far the
largest too small in whole europe
exactly the largest over or available
over is not ours are clear and
that's also the value proposition
the question is a market why
should i book a very good one from you from tier
yes i have a tier
ebwo i say that's right if you say
i only want to drive tier you're
probably better with tier because they
might have another one  locke has more
change app in it and maybe
reacts a bit faster or
whatever our works position is we do
n't solve mobility problem then we
solve problem here is better to
find if you say you are from a to
b then let's see what kind of weather  is
that you are traveling alone are my
friend traveling were a budget and so
on and have the
right offer for you  n song yes and
then it's all about the good experience and
then our what practical with
us the scooter is always the
next app every other app why
if we aggregate the first two three players in
a market we will
always have more than two than that
individual player that means in total
you will always run shorter than a good one in
the end the sack what do you say about that also
asset light so he de facto has
no assets in the sense of
the platform but we have exactly
the assets others operate what we of
course have  is our greatest
asset of
our active customers that means
customer acquisition customer loyalty but the
costs are the customers of
course maintenance costs because they so
every platform needs a certain
incentive to keep it going
so i think it can be assumed
that a platform without any stimuli
from  I don't know if that works like
global scaling, so
my question goes  be aware because
if you research or you can
also read up there is
probably to say but the company
obviously loses several hundred
million euros a year, which is normal in the industry so it's still a
bit high but yes you definitely have
if we still investiv  on the way
where can you lose so much money if
you don't actually pay it only the
platform is the center of attention then we
have to talk a bit about the topic
how do
market structures actually look in our market or
competitive our market i already said at the
beginning that mobility
yes  actually a low involvement factor
is nobody says how awesome i want
a taxi now or i want to sit in the
bus now but you want to go
somewhere that means the first is the
second topic it is a quite
undifferentiated service when
we think about it because now only alone
think of the taxi or private
rental car business ie the centered a
lso the business the drivers drive on
our platform via a competition
platform that means if you
book a rental car from us or via or there
is a 60 percent probability that the
same driver is in the same car
that also means that
differentiation at the product level is then relatively
difficult  do you say how
are
markets actually structured where you say the product is very,
very difficult to differentiate and there is
a low level of involvement
typically you end up in an oligopoly, so a few players
consolidate a large part of the market
and why is that because of the
additional benefit for every additional player
the market is limited if you have a monopoly
is the additional player for the
second bayer there comes in extremely high
both for the customers and for the
driver side because you are not dependent on
a platform until you are basically
employed again  yeah if you
start the second playoff thats great i was
verme  ide because the opportunity costs i.e. the opportunity
to drive on a platform is very low and
the changes will be very low
you then already have licenses you have
all registered documents and the customer also
knows how it works that means
you always see
market structures where you  you have two or
at most three big competitors who can
then also work very well and can
also work profitably
we see that in many cities and many markets
in which we work profitably today these
are always structures and you say two
at most three big players are roughly
in balance
but what is also clear if the number
three is four or five to is not a
business model in which you want to be
three sometimes but four five or six
definitely not that means there will be a
racer pot and what we also see
is when you as a number  one or
two established has it relatively
hard to get there than normal three
or fourth  to be added because it is
simply sluggish flo and wolf one
demands and it is not difficult to
differentiate why should I also make myself
for the third fourth fifth
platform where is the added value for me that
means you have to scale very very quickly at the beginning
that's why we're
through  these went through years of extreme growth before corona came
,
so we increased the company
almost tenfold within four years from 2017 to 2020 in terms of
our goal volume
, we said the strategy must be, we set it down very precisely in 2018 when
I came the businessman must
something on people we have to achieve one
thing in every market in every
city we're active with become a number
one or number two and
have to achieve that in the next three years
because only number 1 and number 2 you'll
climbed that much though on its platform
have that you can earn money in this business
and then it is also
attractive to be in this business  iben
that the father has come here and there is an
investment but you have to get there very, very
quickly if someone else
occupies this position it is very
difficult to threaten from this this
composition and who is who when with whom
this race this right now so against racing yes
so over is of course active in all our
markets in harmony in
hamburg we have a bit of a problem or
have had a bit of a
problem because our our senate says we
actually
don't want to have this licensed rental car business is
better to regulate i think it's a
matter of time before it  here, too, an
agreement has been reached on what that
can look like,
but we are active in berlin, active in
munich, active in europe,
active worldwide, that's something that
a cow, what a platform, we have
other competitors, such as those
in spain or in  southern europe is good
we have bolt coming from eastern europe as
one of our competitors
es  there are of course you could think
about is now, for example, in sixt or is there
one per year or something like that a
competitor doesn't see that like he does because
i don't think the claim is to represent urban
mobility for everyone
at least we don't see them working in the
same customer segment as the
work  whereby Herbert Diess, to whom I
was a world-class athlete recently, and he
said to me, well, he does
n't believe that it can ever
be done profitably, he says that you can
only do it profitably if
you're also a car rental company and
that's on the car, so to speak
It's not for nothing that you can add a rental model to it. He
says that you've also
bought high investments, like Europe. There has to be a
thought behind it, exactly, and
sticks, yes, it can be said from this heritage
because he's his now, but you say
you can do that if you were number
one  then you would be
able to operate the portal, so what he hears from the
partner, so first of all, you k  ann
operate profitably but what we also
hear from the partner you have to take it
seriously it doesn't help to have an app
and say I now offer further
services that's why
some of our sponsors found it difficult
to work with us because you are then
watch out we've integrated a few other
apps and it ca
n't generate any volume at all, yes, we had to
do with the integration and
then have to continue to
operate and provide the integration, but for us
, no business can our value
proposition to the partners, it has to
saying yes be careful we are
a relevant sales channel for you which is
probably more profitable than many
if i use all other sales channels because
we paid
a weird one and a weird one but that is and we
give for volume yes you have to go to
marketing they can take care of payment  we
don't care about first level customer support
, that means that a large part of all
costs fall to us  g for that we get the
weird ones and all in all it should be
very attractive for you also in terms of the
result it's rushing the world
but for that we have to
bring volume to the tour and we come from the
platform business we have a
lot of experience how do I
actually intensify customers
to show certain user behavior
partly through features through promotion
through new systems and so on
and we are currently building that up consistently to the
next area so next for
us that the multi modal use and the
feedback that he got from the partner is
partly calling now announcement what is
you have so many tours going on with you
because we had run the promotion
said that is the campaign we
had run yes not yet
coordinated say crazy what
volume is going on with you and that’s why
i think it’s difficult if
we’ll take your core business  the
example of schernau over other
competitors is our sister company
made the car sharing if you
would go there now and say i would
like to build the platform i think
it will have a similar problem we
said as a platform we are building
now the business is good also as a
spd vice business model the type of
people who hire the  other
processes the company needs the
control logic the company has are
completely different for the platform than
for an asset heavy metal business or
band business or the good business
that is why i believe that our
nation is to exist in extreme
cases the prognosis 56 or something like that would be now
even in five or ten years there will
either still be the new car business
or the app will no longer exist because it is
so i think the value chain
will develop i think
there will be players who are just very,
very good in this essay like the
business  because 80 percent of the
added value probably comes from a scooter provider
h also of the car sharing
is in the operations mainly the
purchase in the maintenance in meknes in the
distribution of the cars the pick up
cleaning and so on probably
only 20 percent of the added value through
him operating the app yes and
maybe not a clue Freising etc
not with us  only 95 percent of the added value
in the control of the marketplace is a
purely digital business and i
think there will be specialists who
deserve the marketplace logic, so to speak,
similar to amazon and then there are
assortment specialists like in adidas
or something else you very well but that
means  now active ice cream power wo
n't be able to price that anymore that's
my hypothesis may be wrong but
i think already at the top the market
is so big and so complex that
specialization is necessary and
sent this market to serve you and
i think we need  excellent asset
providers who simply say that
flying and cars are good for it  s are
maintained and it needs a few
platforms not even a 10 platform
the customer has no added value that’s why only
number one or number two as a
platform has
burned in my opinion the now the cholera has
spoken he now has 2000
people that costs a lot of money but
you also had a
turnover of more than two billion
euros, if i'm going to calculate it correctly, 20 percent or something
more of that remains building is 1 4 million
with that you can already pay 2000 people
quite well so where does
more money burn in the whole promotions or
meanwhile  into marketing where does it go
yes branding is of course an issue,
especially with the rebranding where we have
invested and
will only have to invest significantly more because
we believe being top of mine is one of
the major prerequisites and the
platform business at least for the next
three to
to have the leading position for five years, yes, because as I said,
that is still the case  low involvement yes now
think about where i have
to somehow let myself well now
but also in the city now he
is strong and what options do i
have that means branding is an
issue but a large part is due to the
management of our marketplace
with the asset  heavy business it's a
bit different because the
supply side isn't quite as dynamic, so to speak,
this aside doesn't react to the
cent because it's good as if he
gets it in euros and cents or not
on the driver's side it's something
quite  another thing is
that this demand is super dynamic and the difficult thing is
that the market place is never in balance
you either have too much met
and the drivers can’t all
drive away or you have so much too wide
and not enough the one the drivers
bored also not enough doing
both is both through that means
you always have to try with a cent
on this marketplace at the same time  It's important
to either
bring more or bring more so broadly
and in my
opinion a large part of our
investment in the Rhine also makes sense in a series.
We noticed that some of the
country profile quality is really
profitable  and yet we see
that you need a double-digit percentage in
the pl to keep this marketplace
attractive it's about it has to
be somehow exciting has
to get the pink every now and then or
be acute meisterschwanden promotion
now do five tours i get
something for free if i  into the
car sharing market good and something else it
must be exciting
that i also drive not only
for nature what gives it so so
totally different we will have an
incredible number of sales channels we
have some of the sales channels to
say take that so the commission the
we take yes you can take place m  oh
that you say in some cities
the top riders have low take that as a
new pastor or vice versa you can
go there and say i offer you
five goals in a row to get a
certain bonus
you can single to request makes
no pact do a quest  say i know
that on saturday between 10 o'clock and 12
o'clock or two o'clock at night the most people hit
the wall the way is
clear say if you get into the second verse
you get an extra bonus
culture there are so many possibilities that
intelligently  to control that he says
the driver says that's attractive that
's affordable for us and the customer has
what he needs in supply that means that's
a really exciting topic so that's
why it's really
absolutely top level top grade champions
league marketplace management that's for sure  and
for some it's really times that's
super dynamic that I
compare it to energy
trading or something like that from time to time  day trading on
the stock market was constantly coke and says where
is the supply where is the demand and how
taxable is that of course you ca
n't do it with a thousand hands
and that's why we invest a
lot in the area of science to say h
w do we build some autom
tion  an
algorithm to automate this in order to become faster
and even better and
to control the targeted above all what
does the money we're looking for mean in the end
what I'm looking for new label
customers thought how can it be
that with the  platform business what
rent-a de has to invest so much
is it you have
to scale very quickly at the beginning and that
can you is at the beginning in a low
involvement actually only demands if
you say is an unbeatable offer
either for the customer or for the
driver with it  to drive that means you are
at the beginning you invest a lot in
customer acquisition and new customer
retention so the di  e acquires new customers
also actively keeps there
a part where you say partial
promotions at the beginning of last 2009/10
berlin were forbidden 15 euros through ca
n't go through the whole of berlin is the
window drum but a large part and
carry out berlin so if you
hear that  and then it's actually a
bit more about sixt because
I think there's a quote from
erich sixt that made the founder or the one who first
made it big who says somehow
it had been in
wolfen's product for decades, namely being in his
rental car that  doesn't give a [ __ ]
actually comes from that
now we should drive with sixt europcar it doesn't matter at all so it's
like you
and he says okay because that's how it is and
because I somehow only have limited
money I finally have to be profitable
that used to be  did we have to be
profitable i have to be super aggressive in advertising or brand
building so that
will definitely be extremely aggressive  has
done for decades so they know
that why aren’t you dialog
even more aggressive in advertising why
shouldn’t there be more trouble with gorillas
it’s also a bit like that he doesn’t give a
[ __ ] whether the food comes from
but what the successor is the hotter ones
gorillas they
are just as aggressive in the way
they advertise now is that with
you too that one can or
will expect so it is first of all
i believe in it too i believe that it is
right that we actually said
two backes in which we  invest
one thing is branding and that knows so to speak the
market place on center is also too
small on the demand side
but branding is a very very important point we
are only at the crappy time with our re-branding
campaign so
sorry and german but in a
very  rough time came with corona because
we had to burn like fires
when the markets were actually threatened yes
they didn't move and of
course  ch don't you go and
pave the city if no one
can experience your product yes that's
why we have to think about it we have to
balance it out we're starting now in
france we started a bigger
campaign in the uk a
bigger power now in germany new
campaign we're getting stronger  invest in the topic of
branding and
really step on the gas again in 22
we are, however, we ca
n't become completely aggressive in any way
i think that what
you did was for me one of the
coolest brands that have been
built i'm happy now  see on sixx
advertising because most smiles
when i want this so i am i
right now speaks for me absolutely
is benchmark for german european
branding of a difficult
product but it is rental cars in the service
business in which super g
ended but we were also very aggressive
we are
in this group with our sister company
still within some framework in
which we have to move that means and
say the possibility of really going completely over the top that means for
him we won't do it at all we call
ourselves gorillaz 2 the
possibilities if I mean we
try as aggressively as  is possible
in the existing frame is the frame
also has an advantage because if the topic comes to
fruition it is so
that you say an umbrella brand or
at least a bracket yes
all of these offers can also
promote brand awareness in the sense of
oh look, I know that  but that's why
there's no building trust so on that
means it's difficult so thomas
our fashion doesn't have an easy
task either to
build up a good sustainable branding concept has
been extremely well liked in the last time that
's what's left
we won't be doing it again now
so it burns like burns is first through yes
that's more painful than corner smaller
burns  de gladly that's something that
really just takes a lot of effort
and
what the customers usually don't
understand, especially when it was
time when we internally knew in
which direction the company but
this whole multimodality approach only started
in very few
cities  had available but if I
now for predictions in the next five
years will be like fires because he likes
them still consolidated and at some
point bmw and maybe somehow
daimler will say the thing I'm
out now or someone else is coming buys then
there's the next race okay so
nothing  is as constant as the change
that’s something we have to deal with think about
how this company has changed incredibly in
just three years and before
that when i
came it was for him so my
taxi was
just a taxi
taxi display went so and then have
we then there was the acquisition of
showprep de
chauffeur privé the french n  number
two where we first left the taxi
market yes where we said
we are now going into the mostly
private party business so that the
multimodal topic is set up there are so
many the company will definitely be in
tears again next time no
idea for me  it's also a
fear in the end a structural
disadvantage you'll say it's not like that
but only in my opinion it could be the case
that you belong to these
corporations because of course they
can't lose money endlessly and they
can damage the value of you  it
doesn't really say lift at ubs
so they've been losing money ever since they
are anyway I just
talked somewhere about it's worth almost 90 billion to me
is actually crazy and you
don't even know how are they supposed to
ever really earn money because they
things where you always thought, well
, someone is making self-driving cars so that
it is cheaper or so you
need them, even sell them  ft so it
means that this marketplace will
remain there does a bit of food delivery services let's
see how things go after kona
with you it's like that so
maybe this billion would have been an understatement
if you would bring the thing to the stock exchange
separately and could  without
losing money he has a real
standalone stock market story probably
more than 10 billion so I'll
predict now if you
're on most of the time pretty
sure so first of all I don't think an
investor I said investing company
that earns money sustainably for eternity
then somehow a
bad investor is a game for time
percentage one is no longer fun
our investors are not naive either so
we have very clear
data points where we can also
prove the association that our
investment rate looks like
this but that the return is
proven on the weekly markets  yes we
have in the corona period it was yes  in a
surprisingly short time we
simply said okay we now have to just reduce our cents on our activities when
the market is no longer
moving all markets except 1 were
fully profitable at the country level yes
and that in krone although we only have no
idea 20 percent  of our goal
volume but that's not a position because
we weren't
number one or number two in some markets that
means we need to invest again now when the markets pick up
again to make
sure there's another
spot coming up in the markets we're in
germany in ireland no idea in
spain in greece in all the markets
where we are in this position the
markets are profitable and are
still growing at 8:30 p.m. here that
means it was a very attractive business
but you have to go there and say there is
n't  space for the third or fourth
that means it's a bit go big
or go home either you say i
I go through with it I think that's what's called
I totally understand the side, but
from my point of view it's still on the tipping point
between digital companies that do it
and who have an exciting story telling on the stock exchange
and therefore
sell it that way and therefore also make losses
not checked and the number will of
course not be a dividend,
the money will also be out because we have this really
big vision and you, dear shareholder,
can participate in it and are so
that amazon wants to be like that in the early
middle years and you’re all right
your position or structure
it will probably be 500 companies
also expect you to earn money
from now somehow daimler or
or or bmw they are not in the
mode that you can say now how
we are now losing your money endlessly
because we have to yes  Still
showing some dividends titles almost
and you hear that I imagine it
like that stop and you on d  you're somehow slowing down a loss of millions
here this year
that
we don't want that that's not possible you think
[ __ ] I have to do it but your
cher or don't fit in at all yes well
thank god it's not there like
you thought it would be  yes no laymen at
works they are maybe not the,
so to speak, no idea how they say
i'm kicking one west after the
other on the stock exchange but there are
really very smart people on the
other side who understand the business model
very well
not so in  don't
implement your structure like someone who then i
don't think you get the benefit that
a financial investor thought i get
a high rating as long as i
can show the growth and do the
story but then the question is do
you currently need the rating or say
for me that's a strategic are
west which I don't even want to sell
because I see that's what it's for me when
we say that  private car ownership
maybe will change in the future
, at least in the inner-city
area, then of course the
big orient so no one podcast
with mobile phones has to think about how do I
deal with it and maybe they say that
's an interesting consideration how
much do I actually have to
invest for her  a real option for
the future anyway and then
it's about it it's not like we're
saying we're not going to
invest millions of euros again this year and then
again afterwards but after that he has no plan
how to proceed yes we can do ours
see customers very precisely when is a
positive going to be positive again i have to
invest
and when does the overall business turn
positive where i can say i can also reduce the
overhead with caring this is not a
story that will eventually pay off in ten years
, so for us our goal
is pro  we
actually told jack o'connor that we
would be profitable on a monthly basis at the end of 22 a  we also
want to work from traffic we
've lost a year and a half now, that means
it will somehow work itself out in mid-23 at the
end of three in 24 but that
's a foreseeable time and above all it's
proof that we say even
if we perus we're a good example
are number 1 in peru yes so there they
are who come in for everyone said
now the craft brand is going that we
saw that we could defend our number one without any
problems i.e. i had no problems
although we can
still continue to work on the
market profitably yes so they are  that means we
have enough evidence that we can build up and operate a stable,
sustainable business model
, although we are
far from having optimized
it that there is still so much potential that means
investments are too modern and yet
what some holland would have me in 2009 10
then give  it would actually be detrimental to
say yes and sometimes you would wish you could get
off the board somehow quicker
meeting to get a decision
but we also really saw in the crisis
that it helps a lot
if you didn't see someone that was the first
crisis it won't be the
last we don't believe that corona will be the
enormous one that will recover again
we hold  let's have our feet up
and sit it's clean outside so
calm those who brought it in where everyone
said okay i mean i sat
there in april and it was three weeks
we see that sales have fallen by 90 95
percent yeah you're standing  and
so says cities maniche has no
female bodies lockdown nothing worked
anymore and if you then show or have
you can take a deep breath now of
course we do all the things that are
necessary and say okay we have the
costs under control for today and so on but not
someone who then somehow says and
now we have to get everything out we do
n't do anything and we'll sit out this crisis
we have the opportunity to
suspend it because the fi  to suspend financial resources
we trust you the new
business year is the right thing to wait
huge support
then there is a reward for something like that
also with the rail strike
demand we think is great really
great sometimes
the tours really go through the roof with
us and if you still do that  cleverly
linked to a campaign and he also
uses it as a customer acquisition situation
because that's why the business
is a lot of fun because it's
incredibly dynamic i come
from retail where you say okay you buy
something somehow show no idea
design so somehow production
times then have  you go
sold the goods in the season that customers have
clear lead times our business
is sometimes up to the hour
of the day when we see the weather turning you have to
consider whether e scooter promotion is doing
relatively little are
scheduled for me then we are on
car sharing or rating  put because in the
rain will be  can do well with it through the
area super exciting
do you only believe in yourself were
[music]
okay the second half but
exciting
but i definitely believe that it
will be possible for cars to
drive autonomously and i would be i would
buy it immediately because i am a car myself
drive well i don't need that but
in the country there somehow of
course it will he comes of
course we will somehow smash down 80 kilometers on the autobahn and so
on by truck into the autonomous
and also
be able to do that very probably more
likely than you as anyone
i think  that will come very soon
two three four years maybe when i take a
look at rome yes then it
might look different who then so
the problem is when you talk to the
engineers i was in
california we had
looked at your instrument and there  means that
the market is something like that if we only had autonomously
driving cars super simple the
problem is this  hybrid situation that
you have an unpredictable
person you drive through the area and on
the other side the autonomously driving
car so long story short i think
that will come i think we'll see each other
first in out-of-town areas or
also fast blood i think we'll see that
in public transport i.e. with bus routes
and so on until the really level 5
in person cars in heidelberg comes
i don’t know until 15 years will be six
years i think when it comes it will be
super exciting if we come to
overdo it because then there is
no reason  to
own my own car at all because then
it will really be the case that he won't drive
when you're just in there that's a
car the category the book study and
done from a to
b because your sheryl or expensive
players so clearly what  you
would have a perspective, so let's
take something about an example
, but I've now briefly estimated
that they make about 10 mill  iarden sales with
also a bit stricken
crisis also with the delivery plan with
all of us but it means you are therefore
rated sales factor 9 that means your
value then already over sport
is really a big grain in
germany what yes for companies
like bmw or  that's already a
lot of money, somehow
it's going to be super community report
day annecy pronounces it or with
the bmw ceo with the ios when the factories are in
so you're one of the top
people in the corporations, so to speak, or no
, they're the ones running that, first of all, we have a lot
short line also to the board of directors
but to the cf failure also erwin financial
investors will but what i
think makes a lot of sense because most of the
discussions we have are yes
if the strategy is adopted, so to speak
, and the
strategic goal picture is clear then there is
one  the question of the capital injection
essentially there is no such
thing as saying we are incredulous  there are usually a lot of
synergies from the group that we draw,
there isn’t one significant one here,
but now eichenau is exaggerating day-to-day
business and they have to be careful, however,
or two competitors in the
market more in the sense of where is the
limit
for us it is so that we are actually
very very  a lot of unacknowledged
deletion would be nothing at all ran for
freedom to build the business we
want we are close enough to
transport because the investor is like you
said is that they really say
it is a research topic but on the
side
little energy definitely not so we
are  an affiliated company of daimler
and bmw in the technology sector
don't think it's a business they're completely different
people
how does it come about that the
competitors are so they have
quarrels too so there's
quarreling but they come to us i think it's great
so i don't know what  so whether
they always coordinate with each other
beforehand, you probably already
zumi  ndest, they talk to us with a
unified opinion that's super
pleasant so we notice quite honestly
when we have board meetings we would
n't have the typical side behind it the
typical bmw side it's very very good
alone but we also sit
together with them every month  for two hours and
I had really intensive discussions how did
a zoom holt run as the
next actions what are we planning,
who are we and track and so
on? that is very, very close
cooperation and what gives us
a focus topic, so to speak, so that the
platform management  itself is
actually as part of day-to-day operations
internationalization to continue to
connect neustädter and to add new
areas what we have a big
topic as my job i
actually i ca
n't really have any real
job but my job is
to keep his management team efficient
yes, that they all have freedom  all
resources have in their areas
convince you in your marketing
is strategic to advance your topics
naturally the expansion of our
multi-mode platform yes we have
an advantage now i think since the first
time in three or four years we
really are ahead of all our competitors
what the topic of multi-modality is  as far as that
goes, that always means a wide variety of services
children and the actions offered by others
on our platform and
making that usable we see that our
partners are very satisfied with our
cooperation we see that our end
customers are extremely satisfied we
see that a customer of
more than one mobility use with us de
significantly higher rate at the
same level as someone who only
has to do one thing that means expel that also
strategically that is one of our
essential skills should be the
best person you can call as a reference
when you are
considering as a financial investor sol  l I
now with walt can one do such
the next round or should
I then have your data would then
we know we of course the data
detail that is yes that destroys us
I don’t know at all we
only see  an excerpt yes we
only ever see the excerpt in our
customers doing and we have no idea
we can only estimate it something
between 3 and 12 15 percent we do
our story mode our partners what
but ok i don't want to anymore
i don't need anything  to do what i
want i want a significant
partner for design who brings profitable additional business
for you so
that this transformation can’t be achieved by a
single company how alone
can we say we transform
urban mobility that’s only possible in the
network i firmly believe in it that’s why
i also believe  the development of the
value-added chain is such a
complex problem that no
single company can solve if they all  behind
i do everything by myself yes i
continue to do my own i need my
own scooter i have my own car sharing
with victor so it is so
complicated i think and so
capital intensive i say for alemannia
aachen have it yourself that means it
only works in collaboration and in
networks that has  you have the same
goal say we actually want to minimize owning a
private car stuck in the urban,
so to speak, you have to
collaborate and public transportation
will say that the next point
is something that is that is on the list
but we don’t think that is also a question of
belief  need more
transport only afterwards so the buses
s-bahn underground public transport
there are two g2 look at it the first
thing is logically 50 percent of the
total movement in the city when it
comes to transported via
urban local transport or local public
transport  I have a different opinion
and I say yes but 80 percent  ent of that
is the community have the monthly
ticket they know where you get one where you get off
which what benefit i
actually bring that to show in my app
on the walls would have to do it that’s
why your monthly ticket go there
go out and for the 20 percent who
buy a ticket  was so how big is
really the effort to do it
because it is a house
war to connect the individual providers
also technically it is
not so the super hamburg and cheers
for the girls of the cold are
companies hamburger and so on so there they
are  is really alone in
germany would you have 67 major
integrations in front of you question is what
problem do you actually solve there
and we discussed it for a long time and i
see an upside in the link to
map it holistically
so we will
test it now to just have a look  to come from the hypothesis
to dates and say okay we
can believe a lot just beobac  keep in mind
that
i don't think there was any
communication that's why not monika
germany otherwise you have in
germany otherwise they do in
germany and i'm really excited
so i think that can be great so it
's definitely going to be super exciting i'm
super super
curious about the results there  are that
is a big topic is something to be
considered to be considered to be checked is
then somehow to be publicly included in
transplantation the
other topic is a new country
probably simply branding is
a major training course and I
mean that quite honestly with 2,000
employees  are you no longer
somehow a project manager for a
single topic, but my topic
is to understand where is the best
opportunity for an investment, yes
, it is now more important
somehow to somehow invest 23 million of the brand
campaigns instead of putting the
money into a new development team
responsible temptation to connect or
think i  hr about marketing locally after so
somehow branca you in a city or
something like that we have we have a
thomas manager the global branding team
that we will now switch to an umbrella
brand concept earlier that
patting and yes of course the
commissioner has creative agencies
we're coming to that now so we said we're
just running in patch is I
've seen the first trailers
I like it
there will be at the moment it's still the case that
we worked in a very decentralized way
we're going to
centralize it now because we also say it's a
brand  actually i personally have a
different opinion the brand has to be a dictatorship
everyone can have a say now and if
you work dictatorially that sounds a
bit martial you know what i mean
then it also has to be managed centrally
yes and that means we will now
also control the brand management centrally
Controlling the campaigns centrally in the markets
means this early heart tie  r there could be
six marketing campaigns next
door from england, france, uk and so
on in 20 20 and 21
you wouldn’t see a clear line there they
were always with a very strong local touch
i think that’s basically a
good thing but when you say you need an
international brand  urgently needs to be
done what so if it is definitely extremely extremely dynamic and really
so to speak on the
front line also of digitization of course
immunity walls or so many
core issues that society is currently
moving the world so yes if  he
didn't even want to
say the topic of sustainability
that is that since the current would
say that your net net contribution to
sustainability today
position negative we have neutral so
we make a complete of setting all the
emotions we should have something else
is always  also saw
a bit more good all
natural but we have too  a clear
goal
that we say we want to
work completely neutrally by 2030 instead of
operating it and operating it electrically, for
example the electrification of
our i can't say at all but
our partner taxi fleets and
rental car fleets are moving forward by we has
targeted incentives from taxes by
saying  what also if you go to gate
then we will measure under about 1000 on
top of that we will double the amount to
keep the costs for the team but
it is the old discussion at the core
is the mother can also discuss the whole thing with scooter
providers for example
is that
anyway, first of all, now, today, its an
advantage, in the medium term, it will
then replace cars, then they drive electrically
and so on, but you could say yes, if
the whole program didn't exist, then
everyone would probably be running now
and that would definitely be
more sustainable than the actual scooters
put down that were probably built yes
but what is then I stood  straight away
it would be best if everyone would sit at home
on a farm and just walk and
have no electricity and no tv
and so on but that's
not the reality the question is
whether a crooner will notice how difficult
it is if if  there is no interaction
markets for people no longer moving
and is a basic human need
saying i want to exchange ideas people
namely want to discover things i get mine
from anna i want to move
yes so freedom why does everyone
have a driver’s license when we were 18
before so  in my generation yes i
grew up with the hardships where area
the only way to get out of it was
with the car yes so that's why
the biggest question for me was the question is now how
can i do it if it's a
basic need that it's possible
to present or depict it in a sustainable way
and  I believe that this protects
some good providers unite or
even further in China or i  n
usa it was perhaps
justified at the time,
however, when i look at our partners
today, how conscientious they are with their
assets, how many are investing in
stable, sustainable scooters that
not only last six months, but really last
two or three years with two
batteries  it's
definitely happening it's clearly going
in the right direction
we're already there no but i
still believe that the concept where people
share infrastructure is always more
sustainable like he says i buy my
own infrastructure 90 percent
currently it's on the side of the road  dignified
moves that can't be more sustainable
so alone with logic not so
i would have done that shortly before corinna
with the lawrence
leuschner podcast the founder of tier and he is
also very committed to
sustainability and he also
described it like that somehow
but of course there is a way to get there  first of
all, in an ecological sense, with a deeper footprint than then
maybe we wouldn't want to go
down that path if we continued
like this, but i'm of the
opinion that the medium-term and long-term
is more important than the short-term, of
course, we'll all optimize in the short-term,
but if  if we don't solve the problem in the long term
then we haven't
gained anything and that's why it's so there
has to be a balance and you have to
do so much to somehow compensate for this
possible short-term negative effect
that it's
somehow possible, but that's why
not doing the right thing  even if it's
painful at first it's totally
wrong when we say that it's the
solution for the future that's more
sustainable than everyone owning their own car
their own bike their own
good what percentage of their turnover
pays for it, besides, i
don't know  watch 24 criminal i don't
know i've got myself completely  so i
don't know it goes to the proof
that there is little but i know i
only know if it was a huge amount i would
know because then it
would show up big in the period but ok but that's why
i we didn't forget to say
we did  now more
electric vehicles if we are good
and i know everything with individual electro
pop world as we as we have combustion
engines yes this expansion of the
platform is of course also the
way we are going to push this sustainable
mobility forward that is
when  i'm looking at the electrification of the
fleet again,
that has a lot to
do with training the drivers,
so to speak, if we still have the whole bonus and
center program in the government
and that's the math, it's
much more attractive  driver
to drive an electric car than with the
compass tianjin there are there but
that is of course an invest
ition for the driver and he says okay but we are
right that for many years and more
that means it is not only enough to
get stuck in the center but also to have a
strong dialogue with our
drivers so that you can go this way with
us or partly with the
fleet manager and  if there
are taxi centers but larger operators are what is
actually the most booked reid
about you so something we would like then
which angle will be the most book
super different per city so
let's start from the very end
when I look in Colombia it's that
classic private party because the
infrastructure is completely different from a
comparable
topic, i.e. the licensed rental car business that is
there when i look at ireland with no
idea it is the classic taxi by
far and somehow market leader with a 90
percent market share when i look at berlin
we now have 25
percent  our tours are outside
of the white hell  t and there is
and like taxi and three bidders about
the same as if we somehow no
idea where is that because 75 28 38 percent
taxi rental car and then we have now
good because i personally believe that
within twelve months we will win more than
half of all  doing our tours outside
of the classic because
helling business means scooters bicycles
carsharing everything that goes with it okay
okay so who knows what's going to happen there
growth comes from the growth comes from the
core business it's still growing
extremely strong so we're
always talking about 25%  respective growth but
that the
possibility of offering an existing registered customer further
mobility
offers in a timely manner according to the situation if the promotion is to be given a special use that
is gigantic the potential yes it
is so that is that is well known that
in principle all customers are well known
and they need it  is an app already
installed you just need to say  n
look he's shining the sun do
n't you even want to try the good thing because he
's exactly a minute away from you yes and
I'll even go for an unlock in
four for free the first time that means
driving this and then
keeping the reuse high
until the first two three times
so perfect approaches that is a
gigantic potential so as I said
we went from 0 reitz or a few
hundred to 500,000
within five months and
we see how big
double digits so that's right
treated properly what so when i
hear everything
just thought about it a pity a pity
the podcast too a pity that you ca
n't invest you can actually
only get hold of it to collect data
you then
created a marketplace somehow goes straight ahead
to the crown as it is  a kind
maybe then after corona winner
or loser after kroner winner
is extreme
growth a lot u  so if you think about it
now with the form of an
assumed two million plates
sales times ten so the or the
big ones or nomura painted pilgrims will be
worth two billion
with a 20 percent take that on the market place
with the growth that
you could almost imagine as  investor talk it over
and say it's a great business
just don't talk it over so our
say that it's not
international so great work
I'm happy great German digital company
you sometimes don't see it that way because
they just don't do it that way in this
digital scene  clearly has its own
profile due to the
shareholder structure for good
different
ones you'll soon be well i mean you're not like that you say like i'm now the unicorn ceo or digital company who now
sits with markus lanz can so nope
am now  I don't either. I'm
often told in our pr department you have to do
more, but that's the way it is, I do it
I don't work together with
us to push
that forward yes but I'm glad that I have the most beautiful
story you have so I found it
interesting I learned a lot and pressure is of
course the thumbs
we also do it together fits
exactly into the climate and wool  you don't
kill as well as a disclaimer but
yes also at that time i'm
curious what's going on in marketing now
but advertising is doing now we
are we also follow more aggressively only
now because we win over the pitcher
we're curious what is being
thought up so nicely  it will be good we have
another campaign that is coming in october series it
is not yet from an
agency the new agency will
come out with a q1 okay it's okay again what
will be
thomas has a clear favorite but
that was don't know how
it was yet  this really relaxes
my super exciting time just when
was at the st
[music]